how many voters will cast their vote
this November on the basis of a
candidate's position on abortion survey
data collected by several pollsters
provides a rough gauge when asked by
Gallup how the abortion issue might
affect their vote around two and ten
Americans answer that a candidate must
share their views on the issue that's a
significant single issue block nearly
half however say that abortion will be
one of many important factors while
three and ten say abortion won't be a
factor for them the responses have been
fairly consistent in Gallup surveys for
more than two decades Quinnipiac
University phrases this question
differently from gallops in their latest
poll from December 2017 sixty-four
percent of registered voters said that
they could still vote for a candidate if
they did not agree with the candidate on
the issue of abortion while 29% said
they could not on abortion questions
generally men and women do not differ
for most Americans then abortion is not
a litmus test will abortion be a litmus
test issue for you in November let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI